we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P now I do not
give financial advice to others on the
program but I am going to after
listening to this voicemail I am going
to have to give us some general advice
let's take a listen to it
hey David this is Spencer from Ohio I'm
paying a pretty high portion of my wage
to student loans trying to get rid of
them as soon as possible but with Bernie
Sanders uh likely becoming president
next year when do you think I should
just stop paying my student loans
thank you but yeah so I don't give
personalized financial advice on this
program and this is not personalized
this is a general thing I would not stop
paying my student loans if I were you on
the assumption that Bernie will be
President and Bernie will cancel all of
your student loan debt okay first of all
there's a question as to whether Bernie
will be the next president will Bernie
be the next nominee we got to get past
that hurdle if bernie is the nominee
will he win the 2020 election gotta get
past that hurdle then Bernie would not
be inaugurated for nearly another year
11 months I guess how quickly could he
cancel student loan debt it could be
awhile we don't know so would he even
succeed at doing it so my general advice
to people is don't start getting into
arrears on student loan debt on the idea
that Bernie's going to be president and
cancel the student loan debt now if you
have mechanisms if you are paying extra
towards the student loans and that's
financially taxing you you could
evaluate your financial situation to see
if it makes sense to pay the minimum
which would of course over time leads
you to pay more interest but maybe would
give you a more viable financial
position in the immediate if you
depending on the loans you have and your
employment situation you can ask for
loan a temporary suspension is it called
forbearance where you can suspend making
payments but you've got to go through
that process I would not advise anyone
in the audience to say here's an idea
I'm not going to pay my student loans
anymore I think that that is a very very
bad idea
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we are going
talk about gun girl we've talked about
this gun rights activist Caitlyn Bennett
who was just swarmed by student
protesters at Ohio University we will
also talk about some rural conservative
Oregonians who are interested in
switching states and becoming part of
Idaho in rural or rural Oregon and then
we are going to talk about lawsuits for
non-payment of medical expenses all of
those stories and much more on today's
bonus show tonight Democrats debate will
it be Bernie versus mini Mike just
kidding will it be establishment versus
progressives or whatever join me tonight
starting around 8:15 p.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube and twitch for a debate
pre-show we will then have debate
analysis and post-show hope to see you
there and on today's bonus show